tu penses que c'est pas bien de pleurer
pour une fille sa pas que c'est pas bien
mais disons pour moi franchement même
moi-même si personne me voit je serai je
serai je serai blessé à l'intérieur à
voir pleurer pour une fille ça veut dire
quoi c'est non c'est pas ça pour
moi je suis tellement heureuse que j'ai
envie de le dire à tout le monde j'ai
envie de enfin c'est j'explose quoi
c'est super DS que je l'ai vu j'ai
compris quoi j'ai j'ai eu un flash et je
me suis dit je vivrai quelque chose avec
moi ça m'a rendu malheureuse parce que
je suis restée longtemps avec le cum un
an et demi pourquoi tu l'aimes
Florian parce qu'il est bien
habillé à Paris au Lycée Henri
dans une école de coiffure du 11e
arrondissement comme dans une cité à
chellem à GARCH lesgoness en région
parisienne et dans le sud de la France à
Toulouse ils ont de 5 à 16 ans et il
l'affirment sérieusement l'amour peut
surgir très tôt dans leur
vie les je t'aime ses feuilles
passionnément et tendrement dès la
maternelle mais dis-moi Milie pourquoi
tu pourquoi tu l'aimes Floriant parce
que parce que quoi n VO tout le temps à
la crèche des fois ah depuis la crèche
tu le vois et donc c'est ton amoureux
mais qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça avoir
un amoureux c'est quoi un amoureux c'est
se marier et toi Florient pourquoi tu
l'aimes tant parce que parce que quoi
parce que il Rigo très rigolote vous
pouvez m'expliquer qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire d'être amoureux ça veut dire queon
fait des bisous et des câlins à l'écoute
des cœurs les passions enfantines
restent pudiques et confidentielles chez
les tout petits est-ce que tu as envie
de le dire à tout le monde que tu as un
amoureux non tu as pas envie de
dire et pourtant Jennifer elle le sait
tu un amoureux
ouais mais parce que je voulais dire
mais pas je peux pas alli dire à les
autres à les autres tu veux pas leur
dire et à ton papa à ta maman est-ce que
tu as envie de leur dire non c'est un
secret un peu plus grand à l'école
primaire les sentiments amoureux
s'affinent les enfants du village de
Bruguière près de Toulouse conjuguent le
verbe aimer avec un grand plaisir s'ils
le déclam comme un jeu ils en parlent
aussi avec sérieux vous vous
aimez
pour un copain on a des
sentiments amitié de l'amitié mais pour
un amoureux on a de l'amour sentiment
d'amour des fois quand quand on est plus
grand on se fait des bisous de tout
et en amitié bon c'est pas c'est pas
pareil on se fait pas des bisous sur la
bouche
quo comment on le sait quand on a 10 ans
comment on sait qu'on est
amoureuse comment on le sent ça
qu'est-ce qui se passe ben on a on a
déjà des chocs le premier coup et puis
euh après on
quand quand eu quand on le voit euh
s'amuser avec une autre on est un peu
jaloux ah toi tu as étais jalouse déjà
oui mais qu'est-ce qui s'est passé en
toi tout d'un coup quand tu as senti que
tu étais amoureux
ouais j'étais content parce
que puis après j'ai demandé si elle
m'aimait et après elle a dit oui alors
j'étaismue je sautais partout c'est ton
premier amour toi le garçon que tu as
actuellement non tu enas déjà eu
d'autres un combien tu en as eu ben un
autre et puis celui-là maintenant et
pourquoi tu as eu qu'est-ce qui te fait
dire que le premier c'était un un
premier amour pourquoi c'était un amour
le
premier ben je
l'aimais c'était pas un
copain non c'était un amour oui et ça
fait c'estit quoi quand on aime
ben ça fait drôle quoi c'est bizarre on
sait pas trop quoi dire par exemple
quand tu et quand on nous pose des
questions sur notre fiancé on rougit et
quand tout le monde dit oh il aime alors
tout le alors sait pas où se mettre quoi
ah ouais je la drague un petit peu tu la
dragues comment tu t'y prends c'est quoi
draguer je vois cache-cache avec elle et
se planquer avec ah tu te planques avec
elle ouis et là tu lui dis que tu
l'aimes non j'attends tuattends quoi
j'attends de la mieux connaître faut
mettre nos capacités en valeur par
exemple quoi qu'est-ce que tu as envie
de mettre en valeur de toi pour plaire à
un garçon pour être pour qu'il soit
amoureux to bah que je mets du rouge à
lèvres peut-être ça l'attirerait puis si
je j'essais d faire des petits sourires
et puis est-ce que les boom ça ça aide à
rencontrer les amoureux ah oui je pense
aussi il y a pas peut le rencontrer
autre part mais on peut c'est sur c'est
surtout à C moment là qu'on qu'on
rencontre des
gens autre lieu privilégié et
traditionnel de la rencontre amoureuse
le cinéma entre l'esquimo glacé et le
Happy
dans la pénombre se murmurent toujours
des jeèes éternels des mains des lèvres
se rencontent pour la première fois
comme si le cinéma avait été inventé
pour
ça ces amours d'enfants et d'adolescents
souvent caché l'attitude des parents en
particulier à propos des sentiments
amoureux de leurs enfants choque la
plupart des
jeunes nos parents s'en foutent tout ils
prennent pas ça au sérieux non même si
par exemple ça nous ça pouvait nous
arrivriver de faire des projets d'avenir
avec quelqu'un à l'âge d'adolescence
avec quelqu'un et qu'on pense que c'est
vraiment très important eu je dirais de
toute façon c'est c'est un premier amour
ça durera pas et quand vous aurez 25 ou
30 ans vous trouverez l'homme de votre
vie avec que vous aurez envie d'épouser
avec qui vous aurez envie de vivre je
pense qu'il y en a beaucoup qui
connaissent là-dessus qu'est-ce que vous
attendez vous des adultes par rapport à
vos histoires d'amour être plus
compréhensible je pense ils nous
prennent pas tellement au sérieux donc
ils fut pas vraiment attention à ce que
l'on peut éprouver pour eux il y a les
études les études et les études souvent
on dit on entend les parents dire bon tu
es trop jeune il faut pas prendre ça au
sérieux et c'est un
peu c'est plutôt de leur part que c'est
bas que c'est très bas parce que il nous
gâche un peu nos rêves en disant ça j'en
parle moi c'est toujours ouais c'est une
amourette ça passera alors que quand on
y est dedans c'est pas du tout une
amourette on dirait que ça va durer
toute la vie parce que de toute façon
j'ai pas envie d'en parler à mes parents
donc je sais pas peut-être qu'ils sont
capables de le comprendre c'est
peut-être nous aussi qui sommes un peu
un peu bornés parce qu'ils ont vécu
avant de nous donc si ça se trouve ils
le comprennent très bien on se raconte
même pas ce qu'on ressent pour l'autre
c'est pour ça il c'est rare que que des
jeunes se disent je t'aime ou c'est rare
je serais plutôt timide côté timide
alors ça va ça me va mieux d'écrire que
de le dire alors si je le dis c'est en
anglais parce que pour ça fa ça fait
plus jeune ça passe ça passe mieux en
anglais je sais pas on a la honte on a
la honte de le dire franchement on
pourrait le dire et toi
Carole moi je je suis quand même
d'accord avec elle mais ça dépend des C
il y en a qui qui s'expriment bien quoi
les mecs ouais les mecs ils sont il y en
a avec de l'humour il s'expriment toi tu
as env quoi tu as envie d'entendre un
discours amoureux toi non ça me dit
rien en tout cas ici je sais qu' jamais
on fera un discours c'est impossible
quand on est avec des copains on veut
jouer on est en groupe il y a une meuf
qui passe on la fait viens là et tout
Jer par les macho mais gen quand on est
tout seul on est tranquille on voit une
bonne meuf on la repère on va la chasse
la pécho c'est bien si on la péch pas
coupé on en cherche une autre il y en a
c'est des bouffons il y en a d'autres
ils sont bien il y en a ils vont j'aime
pas quand il y en a qui qui font dire
par quelqu'un d'autre quoi parce
qu'après tout le monde nous prend la
tête c'est pas bon il trouvent jamais
les mots ou alors devant nous il font
sty ils sont bien sincères et par
derrière vont dire ouais je la prends
pour une conne et cetera et
Cera je connais plein de C comme ça ils
vont vous dire devant la meuf quand ils
seront tous seuls ouais je t'aime je
t'aime derrière mais j'en ai rien à
[__] de cette meuf pour moi c'est un
pant c'est un petit pass temps ça
ressemble à rien c'est ça mais les meufs
aussi il faut pas croire hein Sabrina
est-ce que tu penses selon le lieu où on
vit qu'on parle différemment d'amour
ouais je sais pas ça dépend déjà
d'éducation l'éducation qu'on a eu puis
après c'est pas le même milieu quoi
c'est pas pareil ils sont pas dans les
mêmes lieux pour déjà pour s'exprimer
tuà les gens son vient déjà dans un
quartier chic ils ils vont se retrouver
dans un café dans un endroit bien dans
un bar et tout que nous est là dans la
cité on ira pe-re à côté une escalier
pour parler c'est tout tu trouves qu'on
parle moins bien d'amour ouais mais
c'est plus rapide quoi on on éprouve
quand même les chos aussi fortement
ouais je crois que l'amour il est
partout pareil on le dit différemment
sûrement mais mais il est partout pareil
si les mots font souvent défut les
comportements eux laissent encore une
grande place même si les jeunes s'en
défendent un certain romantisme et plus
encore un romantisme certain j'ae les
qui sont doux gentils romantique voilà
c'est quoi avec une jeune fille de ton
âge avoir un comportement romantique ben
c'est le le rêve la douceur le c'est un
peu l'idéal ce qu'on à quoi on pense
quand on est avec un garçon quand on
pense à un garçon on pense au moi je
pense au romantisme qui cell qui sont
autour de toi se défendent d'être
romantique ouais je pense ouais et
pourquoi ton avis ben ils ont un peu
honte peut-être c'est peut-être un pour
eux un peu démodé d'être romantique un
truc comme ça déjà être romantique ça va
2 minutes et après ça ça prend la tête
quoi pour moi romantique si vraiment je
voudrais jouer les romantiqu ça serait
tous les tous les dimanches matin la
meuf a reçoit une rose sur la porte
c'est c'est fini ils sont plus
romantiques comme avant maintenant c'est
sec ouais maintenant c'est comme ça
c'est si tu veux tu veux tu veux pas
tant pis casse-toi tu veux pas sortir
avec moi casse-toi nique-toi ouais voilà
il y a beaucoup de pudeur maintenant je
crois chez les jeunes c'est plus
qu'avant non je pense pas non non non ça
s pas agravé mais il y a quand même il
reste beaucoup de
choses qui qui font en sorte que la
pudeur est là
encore les un dissimulés derrière la
pudeur les autres derrière quelques
expressions crues ils n'en sont pas
moins à la recherche de l'amour pour les
adolescentes du Lycée Henri comme pour
celle de province la quête du prince
charmand n'apparaît pas forcément comme
une image
desuett est-ce qu'on l'espère est-ce
qu'on l'attend encore oui ah oui parce
que c'est le c'est le principe enfin
c'est le non mais dis non oui on croit
encore au Prince Charmant ça un sens ou
ça paraît ridicule des non ça un sens
enfin moi je trouve que ça a un sens il
y a pas de critère c'est quand on le
voit je sais pas c'est l'imprévu
inattendu oui tout à fait nonis un gros
black bien
St
cost non mais
qu'est-ce que tu attends lui qu'il soit
pardon dire quoi Amétis tu attends qu'il
soit comment dans son comportement cool
cool si ses premiers amours indiquent
souvent chez les adolescents un bonheur
de vivre il peut aussi perturber ses
jeunes car il est difficile quelquefois
d'identifier avec certitude un véritable
sentiment amoureux amoureuse je rigole
tout le temps je suis je pense toujours
à la même personne c'est c que j'aime et
je j'ai tendance peut-être à oublier les
études j'ai je suis tellement heureuse
que j'ai envie de le dire à tout le
monde j'ai envie de enfin c'est
j'explose quoi c'est
super ça fait d'abord un petit frisson
sur le coup ça fait un frisson après on
s'en rassurer qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
pour toi Sabrina éprouver un sentiment
amoureux c'est quand je m'attache à
quelqu'un c'est quand tu l'as dans la
tête quand vraiment je pense à lui je
suis Morgane quoi
queand je suis Morgane le grand amour tu
crois toi
non pourquoi tu y crois pas grand amour
moi déjà je pense que pour qu'il y ait
de l'amour déjà il faudrait faudrait que
que dans
l'enfance on est déjà eu on est déjà on
est déjà connu ça quoi on a déjà eu de
l'amour paternel ou quelque chose comme
ça puis après moi à mon avis quelqu'un
qui n'a pas eu d'amour maternel peut pas
connaître le le grand amour avec
quelqu'un avec AC son premier
mec c'est fatal quoion vous avez l'air
tous de parler un peu de de l'amour avec
une certaine gravité c'est grave d'aimer
non je pense pas que ça soit grave au
contraire c'est beau
c'est mais ça rend ça vous rend comment
joyeux mélancolique ah joyeuse c'est je
suis amoureuse j'arrête pas de parler
j'ai le cœur qui bat comme
Stéphan non mais c'est non surtout pas
mélancolique non puis parfois on est
dans un rêve quoi on est absent de du
monde des adultes ou on pense mourir
d'amour c'est un sens ah oui tout à fait
je pense que on pourrait mourir d'amour
aussi bien maintenant maintenant je
pense que bon ça un sens mais c'est
c'est c'est moins réaliste qu'avant
avant c'était enfin je sais pas mais je
pense que c'était c'était moins absurde
parce que quand on dit mourir pour pour
pour l'amour quoi
ça ça ça c'est pas normal quoi même si
même si c'est tantant quoi je veux dire
c'est beau je pense que quand on
s'enflamme
d'amour plus plus on s'enflamme plus ça
termine vite tu es d'accord ce qu'elle
dit Olivier ouais ouais c'est les coups
de foudre d'après moi ça existe pas
enfin c'est c'est pas éternel un coup de
foudre un coup de foudre ça passe ça
peut passer très vite comme ça peut
rester c'est
euh et toi Corine moi je pense que je
rechercherai plutôt l'amour fou que
l'amour du R quoi l'amour fou pour toi
ben une folle passion amoureuse même si
elle se termine mal ou qu'elle se
termine vite plutôt qu'un amour durable
ces adolescents partagés entre l'amour
fou l'amour durable ou le coup de foudre
ne semblent pas ignorer qu'il y a
souvent sur le chemin des cœur des
blessures des peines qui marquent leurs
premiers émois est-ce que tu as déjà été
malheureuse d'amour et ben oui c'est
normal quand il y a l'autre qui nous
quitte ou alors ça c'est tu as déjà été
quitté oui et là tu as vécu ça cétait
quoi le gros chagrin ah oui oui c'était
le gros chagrin qu'est-ce que tu as fait
ben as cherché eu ben je j'ai je j'étais
triste je faisais que que pleurer et
tout mais je j'essayé de pas trop me
renfermer sur moi-même j'en ai parlé
surtout à ma mère et puis elle m'a elle
a essayé de me de me rassurer mais
c'était un premier amour oui tu avais
quel âge j'avais 13 ans Cédric si si ton
amour là du moment ça marche plus
qu'est-ce qui se passe
euh il y a une moitié de moi qui s'en va
quoi j'ai j'aurais plus l'équilibre que
j'avais parce que c'est ça ça devient
une drogue c'est une drogue aussi
l'amour c'est une drogue pour moi
et si j' j'ai pas ma dose tous les jours
je peux pas je peux pas m'en passer quoi
ça a été du plaisir de le vivre et ça a
été de la douleur de le de le laisser
tomber de quitter malheureux c'est un
bien grand mot disons êre triste encore
ça pass et toi tu es dit est-ce que tu
as été malheureux à cause d'une fille à
cause d'une deux filles même à cause de
deux meuf c'est des peines de cœur
s'agit de PE de cœur là ça m'a fait un
choc quoi j'avais envie de pleurer mais
pas
pleurer pleurer comme une comme on dit
pleurer comme une madele connu Madeleine
mais pleurer de rage parce que ça m'a
énervé et toi Sébastien oui tu penses
que c'est pas bien de pleurer pour une
fille sa pas que c'est pas bien mais
disons pour moi franchement même
moi-même si personne me voit je serai je
ser je serai blessé à l'intérieur à voir
pleurer pour une fille ça veut dire quoi
c'est non c'est pas ça pour moi mais au
fond Sébastien toi ici là tu passenses
un peu pour un pour un bagarreur pour un
mec moi je passe pour rien moi je suis
pas un
BAGAR ouais en fait tu es tu es très
sentimental ouais tes copains disent
ouais ouais oua ouais qui m déjà vu à
l'œuvre premiè amours premièr peine mais
aussi premier désir coucher avec sa
copine
c'est pour certains c'est c'est normal
c'est mais bon pour moi personnellement
c'est pas obligatoire Mo pas pour moi
pour toi c'est un simple plaisir ou
c'est aussi une preuve d'amour ah c'est
une preuve d'amour on peut très bien
avoir du désir sans forcément être
amoureux qu'est-ce que tu en penses jeis
pas c'est pareil pour moi oui
c'est pas parce qu'on a une relation
sexuelle
que c'est ça explique l'amour quoi
non on peut on peut le faire sans être
amoureux
mais on peut le faire aussi en état
amoureux mais je pense par contre que
euh on le fait pas de la même façon par
contre c'est c'est quelque
chose de de je sais pas comment dire
mais c'est quelque chose qu'on en soit
quoi alors quand on donne sa virginité à
un garçon c'est que vraiment on l'aime
énormément c'est qu'on s'est retenu
jusqu'à jusqu'au moment et puis jusqu'à
avec tous les autres on s'est retenu
puis avec lui comme on l'aime tellement
au fond toi tu penses encore que les
filles de d'aujourd'hui les garçons sont
très fleur bleu ou c'est ridicule de
penser ça moi je pense enfin moi moi je
suis très fleur bleu mais les autres je
sais pas il faut l'être une idée ben je
crois que oui hein je voulais te dire
que je t'aime
RTI en quoi sont-ils donc différents de
leurs aînés quel regard quel
commentairire font-ils sur la fidélité
sur le mariage l'amour des autres les
grands ce qu'on appelle les
adultes une vie de couple bon c'est vrai
que les adultes il nous donne l'image de
d'un sentiment de lassitude bon banalité
de routine bon c'est dommage parce que
moi je crois que la passion ça peut se
vivre très très longtemps si on se
découvre l'un l'autre je sais pas il
faut pas il faut pas rester inactif quoi
il faut il faut être ensemble et
découvrir des choses ensemble faire des
je sais pas il faut faut trouver
toujours des points commun quoi est-ce
que quand vous pensez amour aujourd'hui
ça veut dire encore mariage ah non pas
du tout pas du
tout c'est fini ça oui c'est c'est je
crois que c'est un peu dépassé Mme ça
exist est-ce que ça veut dire famille
quand même famille
enfant c'est peut-être c'est peut-être
un peu égoïste ce que je vais dire mais
je pense que déjà d'abord quand on pense
à l'amour on pense à
nous-même on pense pas surtout à notre
âge on pense pas tout de suite au
mariage tout de suite aux enfants vu que
le mariage il y a de plus en plus de
jeunes maintenant qui vivent comme ça
sans être marié en concubinage et tout
et je pense que le mariage c'est pas
tellement notre occupation notre et
est-ce que ça veut dire amour est-ce que
ça veut dire fidélité ouis absolu moi
pour moi je trouve que c'est l'amour
c'estut faut de la fidélité sinon je
c'est pas vraiment l'amour intense la
passion le je vois pas je vois pas
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que viendrait
faire l'amour s'il y avait pas la
fidélité je pense l'amour pour moi si
vraiment j'aime une meuf ça sera pour le
mariage ça sera ça sera pour ça quoi
pour faire ma vie faire des enfants et
tout ça mais pour l'instant non je suis
très bien comme je suis non mais moi je
cherche pas ça je veux pas de ça
pourquoi tu veux pas de ça je veux être
célibataire non moi ça me dit rien du
tout quand amour pourquoi ça te dit rien
ça te fait peur non c'est pas ça moi je
préfère qu'on soit disons indépendant
chacun que tu sois de ton côté que moi
je sois de mon côté ce sera plus simple
comme ça Julie amour égale pas mariage
mais est-ce que amour égale forcément
fidélité non ça pour ça
c'est je pense que pas
forcément si on essaie de comprendre
l'autre c'est c'est donc une certaine
liberté on peut aimer au pluriel bah non
je pense que même si on on trompe
quelquun quel qu'on aime vraiment on le
trompe comme ça on le trompe pas pour on
vit on peut pas mener de vies parallèles
vraiment mais en aimant deux personnes
aussi fort l'une que l'autre mais on
peut on peut aimer quelqu'un et puis Mo
avoir une aventure après d'un jour je
sais pas moi on a l'impression que vous
rejetez tous globalement le mariage
pourquoi et ben c'est c'est un
engagement qui qui risque de durer trop
longtemps après et puis surtout quand on
voit ces vieilles personnes qui vivent
ensemble parce qu'ils sont mariés des
fois ils se supportent à peine mais
quand ils sont mariés on les voit qu'
vivent ensemble ça donne pas envie de se
marier on se dit que si c'est pour
devenir comme ça après
coincé ça va
pas partager les adolescents le sentent
également entre leur réussite scolaire
professionnelle et leur épanouissement
amoureux non je pense pas à ce que R
vient qu'est-ce qui est prioritaire dans
dans votre vie l'étude l'amour la
politique vivre dans une autre
société l'étude les études moi je quand
j'aurais mon bas quand j'aurais fait mes
des écoles bon après on verra bien et
puis bien sûr on peut il peut y avoir de
l'amour deant les études mais sera
jamais prioritaire Isabelle est-ce que
pour toi l'amour c'est plus important
que tout oui c'est je crois que c'est
plus important que tout parce que il y a
il y a rien de mieux quoi que tout quoi
c'est plus important que ta réussite
professionnelle oui oui parce qu'il peut
y avoir un amour c'est un réussite
professionnelle qu'est-ce qui te paraît
prioritaire toi ma réussite
professionnel regarde regarde Sébastien
disons l'argent c'est c'est plus dur à
gagner que l'amour tu penses ça toi ah
ouais ah ouais
l'amour l'amour disons l'amour qu'on qui
est vraiment l'amour ce qui est vraiment
l'amour bon ça peut se trouver sans sans
trop se fatiguer tandis que pour
l'argent faut
travailler bien sûr bon
l'épanouissementux c'est peut-être plus
agréable qu'une réussite professionnelle
mais bon ben malheureusement on est dans
un dans un vie où on peut dans une vie
où on peut plus trop en on peut rêver
mais il faut être un peu terre à terre
parce que c'est quand même difficile et
que bon si on réussit pas et qu'on est
amoureux on peut pas vivre d'amour et
d'eau frche malheureusement ça se passe
pas comme des comme dans roméo Juliette
non même
pas gyipsy tu l'aimes John oui tu lui as
dit oui et toi John est-ce que tu lui as
dit
oui